scrolls are the bad guys and you're a
Cree a race of noble warriors noble
warrior heroes we found you
we made you one of us you're not a
bladders thing we'll see that's a
yes-or-no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
what you really are
I think there had a life here
[Music]
what aren't you telling me
you've come a long way but you know as
strong as you think
[Music]
the small cysts the beginning
I'm not going to fight your war
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
oh hey everybody its charlie Merry
Christmas Marvel dropped a surprise
Captain Marvel trailer I'm glad that
more studios are dropping footage this
week I don't know why they don't do it
more the original Deadpool movie did a
Christmas campaign a couple years ago
the 12 days of Deadpool and it was one
of the coolest things ever because it's
Christmas of course there's some new
giveaway stuff that'll be happening at
the end of the video but the Russos have
been saying some things about avengers
endgame that are now relevant to what's
going on during the Captain Marvel movie
so I know everybody has theories about
what's going on with the scrolls and how
that might spill into present day so we
got to break it down but I'll start with
some of the stuff that's happening in
this footage that we haven't addressed
yet mostly the slightly different
narrative that they're putting forward
in this footage than we saw in the last
trailer like this is almost the same
trailer but they just move things around
a little bit and they're trying to be a
little more generic about how they tell
you her origin story in the amount of
information they give you so it just
starts out as a more generic annette
bening voiceover we remade you and then
the scroll is telling her that this war
is only the beginning talking about the
kree-skrull war implying that both sides
are trying to manipulate her to fight
for their side in the war if left
unchecked will consume the universe
that's probably why she has that line of
dialogue where she says I'm not gonna
fight in your war because she could be
talking to anybody it seems like she's
talking to the scrolls though because it
seems like based on the footage they're
trying to turn her against the Kree like
see they've lied to you this whole time
where the good people like they're also
lying to her there been a couple
ridiculous theories that I've seen
recently about how people think that the
scrolls might be the heroes of the
Captain Marvel movie that is not the
case scrolls are very much villains
they're just trying to lie to Captain
Marvel to manipulate her into thinking
that they're on the good side of this
that's why Talos the scroll commander
has that line of dialogue during the
trailer do you want to know who you
really are
the reason they have her in this upside
down contraption is because they're
trying to extract information from her
would the heroes really do something
like that no they would not so with the
trailers trying to tell you is as the
Captain Marvel has to choose her own
path because both of these different
sides are completely terrible like
to get rid of the scrolls she also needs
to get rid of the Cree because they're
just as bad we also got some new
evidence that the cat is probably some
surprise alien or something that just
looks like a cat or it's been modified
in the way that say like rocket has been
modified he looks like a normal raccoon
but underneath the hood so to speak he's
completely different so it seems like
that's also what's going on with the cat
so I don't know how big of a plot point
that's gonna wind up being they might
just have some funny tag with it like
they had with Cosmo of the dog at the
end of the first guardians of the galaxy
movie but they wouldn't put that funny
moment in the trailer with Nick Fury
trying to pet it and it's sort of
swatting him away without them paying
that joke off later in the film
here's the thing though talking more
about Avengers endgame so obviously in
present day Captain Marvel very
important to the Avengers very important
to the future of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but the Captain Marvel movie is
establishing a couple of things for the
very first time most notably the
presence of Scrolls in it sort of a
tutorial for non comic book readers as
to how their powers work what they can
do and what their ongoing role in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is going to be
sort of a more complex replacement for
characters like the shatori like big
space-based villain races albeit with a
little more pathos and a little more
backstory like you don't really get a
whole lot of the [ __ ] our ease back
story they actually explored it a little
bit in the comics like you get to learn
how Thanos started using them as his
sort of go-to cannon fodder for whatever
war he was trying to fight the real
value of the scrolls in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is that they can
masquerade as other characters so you
have that funny twist like I thought you
were my friend this whole time like Nick
Fury says last time I trusted someone I
lost an eye
so obviously the Captain Marvel movie
won't be the last time do you ever see
somebody that you care about or someone
that they get you to care about wind up
being a secret scroll so they think
collectively we all have the theory that
at least one character that we've been
watching this whole time in the Avengers
movies winds up being a scroll I've seen
a couple websites trying to sell a
Secret Invasion subplot theory during
Avengers endgame and the reason why I
don't think that they're going that far
is because they're kind of already doing
that during the Captain Marvel movie you
have Talos his scroll team infiltrating
shield slowly trying to take over earth
so they can use their resources in the
pree scroll war against the Cree so
they're already doing that during the
Captain Marvel movie why would they just
completely recycle that plot during
avengers endgame the Russos came out
recently is sort of talking about them
closing down big character arts from the
a-list Avengers during endgame like this
is the end of a big 10 year journey for
a lot of these actors so they're closing
down their character arcs in really big
ways some you know sort of riding off
into the sunset and retiring effectively
some may be sacrificing themselves but
you know an effective bookend for their
time in the MCU regardless of what
happens to their characters at the end
of the story so right now for the main
characters the main a list Avengers I'm
only expecting a couple big twists one
of them will probably sacrifice
themselves in a big way we'll see
alternate versions of them and they'll
break the laws of the universe as you
know them thanks to Scott Lang in his
quantum energy those are already really
big twists like imagine an Avenger
sacrifices himself like say Captain
America at the end of the story in that
it turns out he was a scroll that'd be a
big middle finger that's why I don't
think that any of those a list Avengers
will wind up being Scrolls so right now
my list of big characters that could be
Scrolls really Thunderbolt Ross is at
the top because he's been such an
[ __ ] and wielded so much power over
the Avengers that it will be a fun
payoff for the character if he turned
out to be a squirrel and it wouldn't
completely break them closing down these
emotional arcs for the Avengers and it
wouldn't be a big middle finger to the
fans although I know a lot of people
have been hoping for Red Hulk I don't
think that they're gonna do that maybe
if William Hurt were a lot younger and
they had the rights to do an actual Hulk
movie and they could build up towards a
Hulk vs. Red Hulk that feels like
something you do in a Hulk solo movie
but it doesn't look like they're gonna
release one anytime soon
there's also the idea that in present
day the Kree could help Captain Marvel
provide fleet support because I don't
think that all of their major fights are
gonna take place on planet Earth
there'll be some sort of space battle so
this is big enough so the Captain Marvel
and say someone like Thor can't handle
it all by themselves but it's big enough
so that you get to see them
quote-unquote Hulk out and use their
full abilities like there's a couple
different types of fights that you have
with the Avengers so you have the
up-close fights you have the group
fights like all of them fighting Thanos
together then you have like the big
giant battles that allow
Thor to use his full abilities without
worrying about collateral damage this is
one of the good things about say like
the Wakanda battles during infinity war
because it gives you that catharsis of
them ripping those enemies to shreds and
you don't really care about them it just
kind of looks cool on screen you need to
have Thor in like a really big giant
battle to let him do stuff like that so
let me know before you've seen the
Captain Marvel movie who do you think in
present day winds up being a secret
scroll and how do you think that the
Kree in the scrolls will be important to
Avengers endgame just remember that even
though the Kree and the scrolls were
both affected by the snap they'll still
continue to be big a presence in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe particularly
in space-based movies like I said though
it's Christmas there's a new round of
that imax ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite Captain Marvel
moment on the video congratulations
March Cell Isaac you're the giveaway
winner from my last big video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details
don't forget infinity war is supposed to
hit Netflix I think today so you could
actually watch that as many times as you
want it's the holiday week but I'll
still be doing videos so leave your
requests in the comments below click
here for my video on all the new once
upon a Deadpool post-credit scenes that
they added to the movie and click here
to watch brie Larson talked about
Avengers endgame in the Captain Marvel
movie thank you so much for watching
merry Christmas everyone I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]